ми з вами з знаходимося на цикарі за ідеєю
а патрона Олексійович приїхав 250 старший
батальйон для того щоб
підірвати нам
давши ви батя на екрані і підробляєте
два пікапа я чітко цифру вам даю за
місяць роботи фортеції бахмут витрачає
45 А вагомих значимого BS можна вивести
Видно немає І ті дві машини будуть нам до
А для того, щоб ми могли
продовжити цю нашу роботу те що
автомобілі цін на наш інструмент провини
наших інструментів оборони бастіо ми не
можемо
та всі машини буквально вже Завтра
передати в роботу Це для нас
спонтанно ми не здалося
робітників у нових
Я хочу знав ще майоні самі нас Петрі
вся Україна до нас швидко приїжджають наші
монтери за раз Приїхавши до Петра Порошенка
і слава Богу чорносно завищує На самому
справі нам боротися
я що ти можеш
[сміх]
інформацію
[музика]
і сьогодні
проходить
[музика]
можна харчування якшу можна харчуванням
поставити ЯК волатині це ситуацію там
ось ви проїхала рибалити а я якась ситуація
обстановка
якою Стан наших дітей у забезпеченні Ми
а хоч кілька сливуд з того чого
побачені
[музика]
наших дітей
важливий
завтра 12
героїв
моя позиція
машини ритуалу наших
Я б від виплатки в Коли уламки заходив
до машини машина доїжджала разом
призначення і хоч живим н Хай за
бортом
за бахмота були ситуації
машин розстрілювала на пацани завищувалася
історія тому ті хто хоче настільки
атакувато
на фронт машини пікапи монтажні машини
він їх собі
Ми за раз
модифіциті та шкіра
у роботу
[музика]